but my dumb ghost husband like she's
always starting that loud enough that
everyone can hear it my dumb ghost
husband great show in the 90s
thank you to our sponsor Babel travel
plans this summer learn to speak like a
local with Babel because with Babel you
can start speaking a new language and
guess what just three weeks get started
right now with 55 off your Babel
subscription for our listeners go to
babel.com DBT that's 55 off at babel.com
DPT you can spell it as
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash DPT rules and
restrictions May apply thank you to our
awesome sponsor Verity Verity is a
family brand founded by Alex his wife
Carrie his twin brother Mike love those
dudes that channels their love of the
beach lifestyle is a clothing for life's
greatest moment Verity crafts clothes
that feel as good as a day at the beach
like this sweatshirt that I'm wearing
right now and they're back by their
guarantee of quality Verity is giving
all dumb people tone listeners an
amazing deal 20 off your order so head
to faritybrand.com DPT and use code
dpt20 at checkout for 20 off your order
hey townies welcome to another episode
of dumb people Town population
he joined in on the town I didn't want
to be like you know oh some people don't
join in
you joined in that's a very that is like
that's a great if you died today and God
forbid but like that you had died
yesterday you died yesterday you're
alive
on your Tombstone uh John gimberlin and
he joined it and he joined it and he
joined it if I don't join in at the
start of something I run the risk of
like getting paralyzed and never joining
it myself
if you wait too long at Double Dutch
you'll never get it
he does not want to be here let me admit
that he hated it but he enjoyed it he
joined it what did I do what am I dying
of no yesterday you survived it shingles
it's so weird it's not a deadly disease
well it's actually not not the human
shingles just like um
which is kind of for your family it's
gonna there you basically now own Elon
Musk and but but it also creates like a
hard thing because everyone in your
family's gonna have to like explain it
and there's a shingles not those
shingles but the shingles so you've
created a situation they'll learn to not
started by saying he died of shingles
yeah
eventually we'll learn but it will be a
hard three months he died of shingles
yes it's like AI eventually it'll learn
right okay uh so the world's getting
Dumber John and so we uh try and piece
through it and understand it through
dumb stories that get sent in by our
awesome fans the way to do it is you
just uh tweet at Daniel Van Kirk at
scolar Brothers on the old Twitter box
and uh hashtag dump people town and then
we can go through it and it tells you
when it came up so we can know who sent
in first I do that I tweet at you you
don't have to if you want if you find a
dumb story send it all yeah you can also
be looking for don't so anytime a dumb
story comes across your feet or whatever
send it to us so I'm gonna pay oh we
don't pay anything we do not we just
shout them out like I have the bartering
system with jokes yes I have the first
my career yeah yeah sure so I have the
first story sent in by Adam freeze or
Adam fries we've had this conversation
I will say this when I go to
um Chick-fil-A which I don't go often
because I don't support their politics
at least sometimes I do ask for the
waffle freeze the waffle free I do like
I like it I like the waffle freeze yes
right I like Foster's fries
that's Fosters oh is that Foster's face
okay you ready for the headline this was
sent in in December of uh last year a
singer who claims she married ghost to
Victorian Soldier complains that he
ruined their Welsh Honeymoon by drinking
too much and trying to get frisky on the
beach oh my gosh who can prove her wrong
that's a long way to say I got drunk by
myself at the beach this is a news wait
what publication is this
this is Apple Spotlight
how is that how would you as a
journalist yeah exactly how would you
care how are we coming online how do you
get you just put in your two weeks you
thought they would say go home and they
said we're gonna have you fill those two
weeks out and you said let's go I have a
gun in my mouth
we're running this and then the Ukraine
story this is on top that is I was gonna
say let's do the the actual newspaper
meeting we're like how are we coming on
that story about the ghost who ruined
her uh wife's honeymoon because he drank
too much and got frisky on the beach do
we have enough we need more sources have
we contacted all the stores see more
sources
I saw a guy on a Welsh on the Welsh
Beach who uh seemed a little drunk
was he drunk yes a woman who married a
ghost has slammed her husband slandered
the dead right for quote ruining their
honeymoon quote ruining it did he run or
did he not ruin it slammed him where in
the Press on on Berry Island she went
straight to the mirror in Wales together
you're not going to believe what my
ghost husband did I remember like you're
right you're 100 he literally ghosted me
I will not believe it I don't know if
her first name is singer or this is what
they're calling her because this is what
how this that's right if it's at her
professional wait the first thing was a
headline right right so this is they're
describing her again in the body I think
so but singer but what if her name is
singer wait say the headline again so
the same singer who claims she married a
ghost a Victorian Soldier complains that
he ruined her well yeah the singer who
otherwise it would just be who's the
actress who's the actress from Footloose
uh Lori Singer John let's go okay
the actress hey Diane Diane Wiest John
Lithgow please John who knows are we
talking about the world according to
GARP yeah all right singer bro card
that's I don't know if her first name is
singer
b-r-o-c-a-r-d-e singer Brocade
uh I was almost gonna say a rage for
that I didn't because that does sound
like her name singer singer card you
know singer bro card I'm a huge singer
bro card fan and she is also a singer
singer singer Bro cards or accused her
non-corporal bow of never picking up the
tab because he obviously does is what
she said because he obviously doesn't
have a bank card guys come on obviously
I'm not a lunatic and trying to get what
she was like she was like he never pays
he doesn't pay because he obviously
doesn't but my dumb ghost husband like
she's always starting that loud enough
that everyone can hear it my dumb ghost
husband great show in the 90s my dumb
Ghost says I guess I'm paying for dinner
again thanks to my dumb ghost husband
wasn't there a show in the 60s like my
cousin the alien what was mom wasn't
there a show with like the alien or The
Man from Uncle or this well man on
fungals the sister who's a singer I
don't know well there was a girl who was
the alien in the 80s who could stop time
that's short yes
what is it
out of this world she's out of this
world or out of this she's out of this
world and then kit I think all right all
right so the pr the performer from
Oxfordshire so she's a singer who
insists she's in love with the ghost of
Victorian soldier named Eduardo
or excuse me
Ed water would be ridiculous
Soldier also accused from what country
drinking too much alcohol she told the
dailies she told the Daily Star and the
Daily Star said yep we're gonna run this
we're running this article Eduardo
thought he was being passionate romantic
by wrestling me to the ground to frolic
in the sand oh my God can you imagine
the people who watched this happen to
her I mean Dan eckroach built a whole
non-sequitur scene about this and
Ghostbusters it's the reason I can't
show my I want to show my kids
Ghostbusters I'm like I don't use it you
think I can yeah
it's not crucial you can fast forward
cross-eyed [__] yes
super weird uh Jay and I so in terms of
hauntings Jay and I stayed at a haunted
hotel in Alaska recently sure so we're
up there and we're like the one was like
wait so we jokingly anytime we're in an
old hotel we say to the person
Place haunted right and she's like yes
it is and so she's like I got a video on
my phone and then she started looking
for the video and it was taking so long
we're gonna go up and jump to race the
video
are you a ghost what's happening so
we're gonna be ghosts by the time we
find this goddamn video I have a video
of the ghost let me I didn't favorite it
why wouldn't you know she's like just so
I'm like ma'am are you on your email
right now you're just deleting junk
emails and so and then finally we get
dressed we come back downstairs she's
like I found the video and she shows us
the chandelier that's right above our
head little pieces of it are shaking and
like it's a video like she clearly shot
it with her phone and it's like a video
every little thing where like were
people walking on the ceiling above it
because that could have maybe had it
she's like no it's just this one piece
then it's this piece and it's this piece
it's like It's haunting I'm like so I
don't know so maybe Eduardo actually
exists thought he was just wrestling
passion and romantic restaurant on the
ground frog exam but I was trying to
share my ice cream with him oh my gosh
and it went everywhere all over my face
you can eat ice cream he can contain ice
cream but not a bank card just you're
walking by on the beach
alcohol and ice cream but not a bank
card it's all over my face in my hair
and in the course of the sand stuck to
it so I looked like I had a fight with a
giant seagull you did not like that I'm
gonna show you singer it says a woman
who has fun singer bro card is like I
want to call her like whales
look at her look at this woman she Welsh
or is she vacationing Katy Perry Oh no
singer broke hard she's beautiful
actually
I mean she kind of has the same haircut
as the comedian who's in England April
Richardson oh yeah who I love Richardson
looks so funny not as cute but April
Richardson all right a woman who married
a ghost pictured in October was the
ghost picture in October she saw this
woman this picture sometimes all right
brocard admitted the honeymoon should
have been amazing
instead ruined by our unpredictable
lover who hit the mini bar hard of
course the minibar because no one can
see that this is just a lifebuilter on
deflection did he hit the mini bar on
everybody where does it come from how
did how did the journalists at the star
here to go investigate this stuff how
did she call the paper and she's like oh
I have a story for you guys I don't this
all tracks me especially in this next
comic The Newlywed also revealed that
Eduardo no now it says Eduardo so it was
a lot I hear about the right the author
I copied and pasted it it said Eduardo
and now it says Edwards you didn't type
this you didn't read it sure you didn't
type this out who added the d The Dead
Guy D for dead
because he's drunk indeed stands for
drunk all right suggests he suggested
ordering 12 bottles of the best
champagne to the room when they made
when they made it to the hotel knowing
full well that the boy that the bill
would fall on her right so this is like
we've talked about this this is like
when a pet psychic comes over to your
house looks in your dog's face and is
like he's not happy about the stock
market you're like I can't argue with
you yeah yeah there's no way like so
he's not happy about the stock market
we're making this up this isn't she's
not thinking
broadly enough if she has a ghost I mean
how many ways can you like make money
this whole like he's not contributing
thing right he could look at other
people's bank information you know you
could you could still you're not
utilizing your ghost the right yeah it's
the PIN numbers at least is this ghost
her excuse for all her bad behavior is a
life built on deflection last week she
shared a video of the pair exchanging
her their vows on Instagram well I think
this is going to be a pretty one-sided
yeah this is a real John Cena who
married them what does the is the I
don't know like who who what what priest
online
can be heard saying okay bro car can be
heard saying I do in the clip and
answering the answering he does this for
her girl oh my gosh during the touching
ceremony touching not very often at a
wedding do you light a candle for the
people that are no longer with us and
one of them is the group yeah I would
say her as well yeah all right while
it's not quite clear what Ed Eduardo
chose to wear for his big day brocard
opted for a Gothic black dress and Veil
uh you know why to what she's probably
like hey this isn't my funeral with the
venue adorned with a series of romantic
candles it comes as in October brecard
left uh this morning viewers in
hysterics after she claimed her ghost
lover appeared on set with her halfway
through her interview with Phillip
Schofield and Holly Willoughby brocard
shrieked and revealed Eduardo was here
so she's now going on TV shows what TV
show is this wake up London no all right
she added that the spirit who once
ghosted her foreign
was not pleased with uh with her talking
about him on TV and that he doesn't like
Phillip Schofield
that's a great aside
he doesn't like you why don't you like
him why don't you his breath his breath
is Randy and I were just talking about
this is a bit we want to do and stand up
is the person who talks [__] about
people through their cute little dog she
is a bad person yeah
do you like what she's wearing you don't
like what she's wearing her hair is so
bad it's so ugly you're so good but her
hair is so stupid they are too close to
us
she's a performer viewers in the show's
presenters including Allison Hammond who
was heard cackle in the background
during broke bro card segment were
amused by the spiritual singers
unconventional Love Story dressed in
black wearing a wedding dress brocard
who claims she met Eduardo during a
thunderstorm as she struggled to sleep
following a disagreement with a friend
and she was looking forward to their
nuptials okay they should begin an
interview she shrieks suddenly that
probably wasn't weird at all this is the
opening of of of American Idol when they
put on the person who's like clearly has
mental health yeah and things they can
sing like Michael Jackson is terrible
they don't even go this far no they're
they're like this is train wreck TV
we're putting this crazy lady on so at
the beginning of the interview she
shrieks suddenly causing Holly
Willoughby who was dressed as Wednesday
Adams to jump wait what again there's
another picture of this is bro card
she was seen holding a bridal crown that
tied her Black Veil to her head and
claimed Eduardo had hit it he's here she
said immediately Phil who was dressed as
Uncle Fester began to move around the
couch and pointed out he couldn't see
that is he here is he here
Eduardo doesn't like you tuition
presenter said well that's fair enough
I'm not marrying him is this like a
Halloween themed I bet it is on December
I thought sorry he can be rude sometimes
she apologized resuming the wedding talk
she admitted she found it difficult to
find a church that would marry him we
talked about this because I think
there's a bit of an issue with religion
in the afterlife not all the priests
believe after life has a lot to do with
religion as she spoke Eduardo knocked
her headpiece once again and the singer
accused him of ruining her wedding day
by making her look like an idiot TV we
should talk to her for a second I don't
think Eduardo wants to be married too no
right Edward is a free if she's treating
there you go
if she's treating this is all real then
I'm going to speak to her as a real
person in a relationship and go let's
look at the facts here he may not just
be he drinks too much he hits you with
ice he accosted her in her sleep during
the thunderstorm borderline rape I'm not
saying he's not a good guy I know
hopefully it's not any of that right
listen where there's Thunder there's
lightning I've always said and love
thank you how old is the singer I almost
gave it away but how old is you've seen
brocard how old is she 43 uh-huh 36 what
do you think John
uh
48 48 years old get your answers in
townies she either looks really good or
really bad singer bro card is 96 now I'm
kidding is 38 years old
Jason very nice maybe he doesn't like it
do you think it's a sign she asked Phil
and Holly uh well the last time you came
and talked about him on the show he
ghosted you for a week Phil said with
Bro cards Phil needs to get out of there
by the way these are the show hosts on
the show well they went all out this has
to be a Halloween themed up more like a
Wednesday yeah
successful but that came out around
Halloween didn't it yeah maybe he
doesn't improve about being spoken about
broke hard continued Phil was determined
to get the spirit to form a trick for
him and ask Eduardo I wonder whether
there is any way you could make my
script move or something is there
anything you could do Eduardo can you
flicker the candles for bro card he said
don't test him bro card said this is
insane morning social segments are
usually like three minutes long and then
we adopt a dog
the then wife to be said she hoped
Eduardo would still be standing at the
altar after her appearance on this
morning to which Phil dead band how will
you know
she knows when he's there Phil back off
dude I'm anti-filled he's more present
than your dumb wife I feel his presence
brocard revealed that uh she didn't
believe in ghosts before she met Eduardo
but was turned around by the spirit I
had tears streaming down my face it was
really intense and I think it was the
fact that it was so intense that
converted me okay and there you go and
that is the first story they're not
they're not together I don't think it
worked out you know and I think she
should just start playing the field and
I'm talking about the field alive or
dead she could date anyone yeah you want
to date Albert Einstein he's probably
floating around do they sign a prenup or
a post-nup on that I don't know plenty
of fish in the outer realm a Victorian
Soldier yeah what were the wars that's
what I was you know you should interview
her and really don't treat her like Phil
deadbeat let's learn about Eduardo the
great everything the great Victorian
Awards you can't give like
two
insane details right be like that's it
that's my like backstory Phil's not
known for really dig in and he was also
dressed like Uncle Fester so there you
go all right there you go Love Story one
first time he's gotta love it John
gambling's with us we're gonna talk
about what he's got going on what we
have going on right after the break it's
dumb people Town don't go anywhere
hey guys welcome back to the show uh
before we get into how you can support
John and watch him in a new show I watch
his old stuff too he's great on Broad
City uh let's get that is old stuff yeah
that's really old damn good oh my God
it's so great
let's talk about that there's so much
since then but I think that's probably
what people most immediately is that I
will get into that in a second uh let's
talk about what we got going on uh July
19th at a comedy store we're doing uh
tag it again which is our show where we
have comedians friends go up and do
their stand up and I are off to the side
writing tags and come on stage and pitch
and they're in the belly room it's just
a real fun space Oh my God the energy up
there is amazing we should hopefully
sell it out we sold out the one in uh at
the end in April and then hopefully the
one in uh June which we're recording
this before it happens but hopefully
that's gonna sell out too then we're
doing it at Largo on uh on August 1st we
also the Big Show that we're doing is we
took our stand up and wrote it into a
two-man one-man show kind of I would say
in the van dean of the great hopefully
the great Mike Birbiglia shows that he's
done Neil Brennan's blocks was really
inspirational for us too taking our
stand up that we're doing right now and
putting a framework of a great story
that happened we're going to take an
evening to make the case for why you
should choose to be a parent if that's
in your purview yeah uh make the case
for parenting by telling you how shitty
is to be how difficult it is and all the
problems you make and the mistakes you
make but really it's a it's a very
optimistic uh show which I know if you
know us that's who we are unless we're
watching sports we're very optimistic so
uh really cool show at Dynasty
typewriter two shows seven and ten
o'clock on Monday July 24th all those
ticket links will be available at
superscars.com you want to sell those
out so if you're in La please please
please come to that Daniel go to
danielvangirk.com or at Daniel Van Kirk
on Instagram I have a show here in La
called best bet comedy it's great follow
that show at Best Bet comedy Irene two
and I host that it's wonderful I'm not
sure when this is dropping but we have
shows that UCB in July and then in
August as well so if you follow me
you'll keep up to date on that otherwise
I'll be in Chicago Austin
Denver more dates are all being
announced at danielvankirk.com plus some
due to the current double strike we're
in right now yeah uh I'm doing some
digital shows because it's just limited
in type of the works that we can do so
if you go to danielvankirk.com and you
want to do one of those they're really
fun like movie watch alongs where I just
do like a rift track so it's so fun so
it's a good time and it's chill all at
danielvankirk.com all right John season
two of the after party yes I'm in that
yeah that comes out July 12th I believe
that's great do you love what you did in
that do I love what I did yeah how do
you feel about it it was fun you know
I'm in like um
a few episodes and then like one episode
I'm in or a couple episodes I'm in a
bunch and then I sort of appear it's
great but it was really fun the cast is
great the directors were all great
um love it what did you say it again
July 12 like 12 12. great okay so that
is a Wednesday I believe that's apple
right you guys have you you weren't
looking at any of those dates you just
have these calendars
July 12th is a Wednesday that is how do
you know that because we're gonna do
this show is on the 11th and I know
that's on a Tuesday
it is weird how many things I can't
remember but once I get dates in your
head they just stick in there and then I
mean forget it you're remembering all of
it you know exactly forget about it you
can remember all your dates I can tell
you so much that's all we have in our
lives right now
yeah so that's coming out I haven't
worked a ton
um you know I'm on Twitter I rarely
tweet and I said No at gember licking
and uh you know I'm working on stuff but
yes you know I'm in sort of a
gestational live stuff are you live
improvising at all here I'm starting uh
yeah I'm I'm I don't have any like
actual dates
um
right now but I'm trying like you know
every week or two to jump in on shelves
watch out for that look at me on
Instagram followed uh and you'll find
out follow him and find out
follow around and find out yeah yeah
what if he said follow around and [__]
out uh well I got a story I got another
dumb story let's jump into uh this was
sent in from uh Greg Quinn at cinemat
T Combs cinematic homes cinematic
cinematic home cinematic I don't know
why I can't read uh it's really going to
be detrimental to the next part field
trip photo field trip you have kids you
have kids field trip photo appearing to
show Rochester sixth graders appear this
by the way appearing twice in the
headlines the worst writer ever yeah
appearing to show Rochester sixth
graders appear to pole dance at Nikki's
Lounge infuriates trustee so Nikki
launches a strip club yeah yeah that's
Chester hey man kids got to get a buffet
somewhere Rochester Hills Michigan
Rochester Fox 2 which is nice yeah uh
that's not bad right yes the Rochester
communities school district is under
Fire after sixth graders were pictured
practicing pole dancing while on a class
field trip yeah now hold on what was the
field trip for can I just tell you we
had to go to the Cahokia mountains same
thing our
is like old Native American burial
grounds outside of St Louis
you just go out and look at ground and
you just look at him they have like
stories they had a museum and there was
like a story and our mom was like I'll
I'll chaperone this with you guys we get
in and they're like showing like a 45
minute like she is she's out cold
snoring out loudly to the point they're
like who is being disrespectful about
the Coqui amounts and we're like it's
our mom sorry she's snoring better than
running around and laughing and
screaming kids and you go and you slip
uh dollar bills between the men in each
of them
yeah cause that's the deal did they did
the bus break down and then they were
like well here it's it's raining or it's
cold I'm gonna get into it right now
okay okay all right here we go ahead I
want to hear what either only one
trustee is the other ones are like oh I
know that the other ones get it it's
like it's good okay whatever shut these
kids up remember you took the kids off
our plate have you tried the General
Tso's chicken there it's unbelievable uh
the band teacher there is one trusted
he's like hey it's not screen time being
active and that other [__] iPads the
band teacher also the band teacher who's
like in four bands and high all day long
the band teacher took the kids to visit
the Detroit Symphony Orchestra on
November 16th and stop for lunch at
Nikki's Pizza which is attached to
Nikki's Lounge okay I need to know tell
me now did you look up Nikki's Lounge I
did see a picture all right you know
what I'm saying like did you Yelp them
I'm gonna help it right yeah but right
now I'm going to yell our podcast within
a podcast the students were moved from
Nikki's Pizza due tonight KK
S Pizza like Nikki sticks due to a lack
of available space to the lounge so they
were they were moved from Nikki's Pizza
to Lounge so this tells me that the band
teacher is not that organized of a guy
he was like we're gonna go to the
symphony and then we'll figure out where
we're gonna eat lunch on a field trip
you can figure out yeah
rank Forest Cafe
make it Rainforest Cafe hey folks
Pac-Man Jones no literally no foresight
by this guy
okay here we go uh and that's when some
of them started playing on the polls the
environment is inappropriate for
students Rochester School Board member
Andrew Weaver this is not by the way
that's That's How It Was Written
Rochester oh said Rochester sorry this
is not a place where we should have
students on a sanctioned school trip
um sorry why were they moved from the
pizza part because there was no room
there was no room I'm going to show you
a picture so they serve pizza in the
strip club oh yeah yeah if they knew
students were going to end up in Nikki's
Lounge before the trip started they
should that should have been clearly
communicated that wasn't approximately
how many sixth graders from Hart Middle
School in Rochester plus how many
chaperones and staff so there's a lot of
people who are allowing this to happen
how many seasons I wondered if it was
just one how many students were on the
field how many students how many
students on the field trip 80.
40 40. Ram what do you think how many
students on the field trip uh 120. get
your answers in there were 146th graders
wow how many chaperones how many
chaperones left unless you want one for
every three isn't that the rule I don't
throw your guessing
140 you said I'm gonna say six six
chaperones for 140. I think this was
this whole thing's a mess it's
understaffed what do you think
fourteen fourteen one for ten six Dan
said six uh eight he's over here
when you were like six this might be
more shocking 29 chaperones were on this
tip yeah okay so the problem there is
it's a lot of people thinking someone
else is doing yeah someone else check
this out right too many cooks the
trustee is calling for an investigation
saying the teacher showed poor judgment
Apparently after some pizza a couple
students found some polls
what are you gonna do so there's a
169 people 69 dude
going into this pizza I mean Pizza slash
strip club they can't handle it what
place could you go into with that many
no one can handle that number these are
sixth graders so I'm in our world I'm
sure some of them exactly know what a
stripper pole is some of them no idea
either way around that age they'll
they'll climb anything
they're there for the climb they're
there for how it makes them feel
listening you're going to get pole Burns
Dan I'm just gonna say a couple of sixth
graders found the pole and they made 48
bucks I mean what are we yeah and you
can fit are you ready
they are decorations according to
Nikki's Pizza
these bowls just decoration right that's
just another ceiling pole in the middle
of the room that's brass it says
decoration you're not getting an
entertainment life is that a
load-bearing pole no so I invite anyone
to go on their website and see what goes
on in that bar they are not decorations
[Laughter]
and he's like I will refute this
immediately I'm gonna read an uh a Yelp
review from Heather oh been wanting to
try
[Music]
it's Michigan I've been wanting to try
this pizza from Michigan
you've been wanting to try this pizza
and try the pizza for so long we went to
the we went there and were ignored no
one even came over and greet us we got
up and left okay so that's the
restaurant that's not the lounge right
no all right if I know kids are going to
be eating in an adult establishment that
is designed for adult entertainment I
would say the students should not be in
that environment quote Weaver
the owner of Nikki's Pizza did not want
to go on camera but she did say this is
not a strip joint it's never been a
strip joint and anyone who said that or
insinuates that it might be a strip
joint is quote just wrong and she is
insulted by that she says it's a pizza
place is it a strip joint she's saying
it's not with poles what do they do in
the lounge
this is crazy from the Rochester
Community Schools Lori Green said at no
time were students exposed to
inappropriate activity during the field
trip any questions or concerns from the
parents and caregivers do students end
of the field trip were addressed
immediately by school administrations
kids it's not
this is the kids on the stripper poles
oh my God doing doing what kids do on
the Photoshop on this they put like
marks on their faces with an iPhone who
they are yeah yeah that's iPhone let me
see that so there's three
there are three stripper poles yeah
decorative stripper pole in front of
couches it's not a stage right they look
like individual platforms like they're
on a little stage platform they're on
little stage plants so in front of
Lounge couches and final Lounge cat this
is very clearly adult entertainment I
was expecting it to look like more like
a red and sleazy but it has that like
well it is two in the afternoon yes but
it has a sort of like clean like it's
like an AI when they go to the strip
club yeah it almost looks like if there
were Super Poles in a hotel lobby yes
yes so so much by the way if you've ever
stayed at Nikki's Hotel I mean you know
well but so so maybe Nikki's Motel 6
Nikki's motels Ah that's terrible Nikki
Sixx is Motel it's a rock and roll Motel
I like Nikki's this is not like light to
hold but you guys hold on just hold it
no no put it put it back in they're on a
run with about this hotel it's okay
sorry uh he's gotta hold it all right
we're almost done uh but this is what
I'm talking staff I think there's a
chance that it's not a strip club and I
think it's one of those things where
they're like for an adult Lounge we're
gonna put a pole in front of things they
could just be like a woman gets drunk
we'll see who gets drunk
they just have dancers
class that's the question do they employ
dancers or strippers or is it just for
the Patriots
on their hit like pizza on their
and let us know if you've gone to
Nikki's in Rochester Michigan if you're
a fan of this show if you live in Ann
Arbor please go there let us know what
happens at night and so we so we can
solve this mystery there you go story
story number two down the books Daniel
give us a little taste so that we can
get this thing back hooked up
sorry oh golf cart Shenanigans golf cart
Shenanigans all that on the other side
John gemberling's with us let's go do
this it's done people tell us here on
the other side of the break
[Music]
we are sponsored by farity summer starts
with Verity you can look good and stay
cool with effortless warm weather styles
with their T's their shorts their swim
and more you'll be ready for whatever
this season throws at you I love the
Faraday Brothers Mike and Alex they're
twins twin brothers who are in business
with each other and I just Jay and I
feel so connected to those guys the
quality of clothes they have Wherever I
Go people are like what are you wearing
I'm like ferrity so Father's Day came
around recently and my wife and my
daughter went to Faraday and got me
clothes and I was so excited and I'm
wearing I will not stop wearing the
stuff even as it gets warm to wear the
sweatshirt I have a little of my great
flowered shirts from them that I wear
short sleeve that I'm wearing on stage
they look so cool I've got the shorts I
was uh swimming this past week I was in
New York and I was swimming the ocean in
my all day shorts I ever I have so many
different types of their clothes is
every piece is designed for it to be a
lifetime favorite of yours yes and if
anything ever happens a long way Verity
will replace or fix your clothes for
life no matter what I like so here's
what I'm gonna say to you guys they love
that with their I love that they're
sponsoring our podcast they love our
podcast let's keep them as sponsors by
supporting them I love what you wear
that's right so far he's given all dumb
people Town listeners an amazing deal 20
off your order head to
veritybrand.com DPT and use the code
dpt20 at checkout 20 off it's amazing
support these guys because they support
us and their stuff is awesome
Italian I'm learning how to speak
Italian I shop so much I can speak
Italian
listen I'm learning Italian it's so easy
to do I'm learning through Babel simple
you know what I love about what they do
for it's easy it's on my phone the app
is perfect and simple and easy to
navigate but they send me little
reminders like hey you want to learn a
little bit more today it's never I never
feel like they're chiding me I always
feel like it's like hey you want to just
add to what you know and it's been great
it's an easy way to learn they're almost
like games as you learn how to learn the
language and multiple choices it's been
so much fun and probably the easiest way
I've learned Hebrew in my life I've
learned Spanish in my life in classes
and stuff this is the easiest and most
fun three weeks to continue you can
teach you how to learn they kind of take
you back to when you were a kid and we
learned language we were at our Peak at
language learning when we were our kids
and Babel Has kind of figured that out
and so they know how to take you back to
that time like you said with games and
with these little reminders and it's so
easy if it's on your phone it's easy to
find traveling this summer right Dan I
think now you can start well they have
quick 10-minute lessons that are
designed over by over 150 language
experts to help you start speaking that
new language here's something that I
love they say this I keep repeating it
to people Babel is designed by real
people for real conversation that's
right and I feel it as I'm learning
that's awesome so guys here's a special
all right right now we have a deal for
our listeners you can go and get 55 55
percent off your Babel subscription but
only for our listeners at babel.com DPT
get 55 off babel.com DPT it's spelled
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash DPT rules and
restrictions
stick around make a sound there's more
than people town
hey guys welcome back to the show Daniel
take us home uh before I do this I won't
mind everybody we have a patreon that
you can joining us only five bucks a
month you get your dumb news stories
that you can send in you can listen to
other townies dumb news stories from
their life or you can send us old school
stories like pre-2010 yeah just for you
sometimes I even do a green thing on
there oh yeah here we go ready yes let's
do it uh drunk woman drove golf cart on
Florida Highway you knew the state I
didn't have to say that I mean there's a
moment where it's probably like freeing
I would imagine driving a golf cart on a
highway is like but you're doing a lot
of this you're doing a lot of go around
Dan driving a golf cart on a highway is
like going to your grade school at night
as a kid you're like this isn't where
this should be happening it's just I
feel weird a woman with an open bottle
of Jack Daniels whiskey in a bag of
course she's not an idiot I want the
I just want to get busted
Daniel's whiskey in a bag was arrested
for driving a golf cart on Florida's
busiest Interstate while drunk no [__]
of course according to an arrest report
the woman was arrested Saturday night
there's a quick little dumpster I'm just
trying to play through I'm just gonna
emerge yeah
I like how it feels in my hair it's like
going one mile an hour the smell on a
Florida Highway by the way just like the
gasoline asphalt heat and exhaust if
anyone could get taken out by a gator
who's this woman right here yeah no no
and also if you've ever driven a golf
cart you put your foot all the way down
to accelerate and you go like five miles
per hour yeah I think 10 is usually the
max 10 is the max I could be wrong
unless it's a souped-up one because
sometimes they put a little motor in
that thing yeah
she uh she was arrested Saturday night
on the shoulder of Interstate 95 night
yeah night she's facing misdemeanor
charges you get a golf cart at night of
disorderly conduct in a public place and
resisting an officer without violence
which is I think just more let go of me
no no or just they're like at man give
me your hands
or is it just like keeping driving while
they're trying to grab it ma'am don't
make us put this
Florida Highway Patrol report a
semi-truck driver spotted the woman
driving in the golf cart in the center
lane she's not even over standard Lane
that's good I mean it's not easy to pass
on a highway no she had to get to the
center she's a good um signal and she
can get all the way to the Middle Lane
golf course in the centerland of
Interstate 95 in Brevard County which is
the heart of Florida's Space Coast the
truck driver advised that she observed
the advised she observed the driver of
the golf cart passing out while driving
I have I'm reporting a
sleeping drunken golf car driver in the
center lane this is another this is a
super dumb part of this story where a
good person does a very dumb thing the
truck driver used her own semi to steer
the golf court cart to the shoulder of
the interstate no so This Woman's
driving bag in hand in and out of sleep
and the semi's like you know what I'm
gonna what's what Fast and the Furious
skills
she's like I'm going to guide this with
a semi truck with a semi this feels like
a scene that was deleted from 2001 Space
Odyssey sure like we can do we can do it
if we just push this thing yes God so
she's using a [__] semi truck to get
a job guide a golf car off to the side
without it going under one of the wheels
or and driving up over this person yes
now you say she's a good person doing a
dumb thing well she had a good idea I'd
be like I gotta get her off the road she
could have been like this might be
really fun yeah like I think she was
like I could crush a woman under the
guise of how
yeah once on the shoulder the truck
driver grabbed the keys to the golf cart
as the woman tried to drive away once
Trooper he can't keep starting sentences
[Music]
once Troopers arrived at the scene there
was a golf course
[Music]
Jack Daniels all over her body
she couldn't quite explain it she
wouldn't just stand there okay
she kind of was a human crash tester
Troopers arrive at the scene the woman
started arguing with them no [__]
she's not gonna just be calm she woke up
to argue she woke up arguing yeah you
know how you like you wake up she'll be
like where am I she argued with them
insisting that she needed her bag yeah
we know what's in the bag oh we know
it's inside the bag Troopers found an
open bottle of Jack Daniel's Tennessee
fire whiskey now Tennessee fire this is
where I have to speak can't step in get
in here
Tennessee fire whiskey is a really great
version of Jack Daniels sure it is
Fireball is horrible for you first of
all don't does it burn your throat yes
it is cinnamon and it's good but the
reason is is if you ever find yourself
in a situation where somebody's like
we're doing Fireball don't Fireballs the
lowest grade form of whiskey that they
can call it that and then they just had
food coloring Jack Daniels has to meet
all the requirements of actual Jack
Daniels whiskey so it's gonna be then
they actually put cinnamon in it I do
enjoy a very chilled if the night is
right we're in Vegas we just got done
doing an RV Convention Show okay I would
then you're like help screw it let's do
it all right so I will attest
Tennessee fire whiskey is the way to go
okay however not like this you don't
need a golf cart or a bag or the
interstate to have a good time is it
like a fancy whiskey or you just no it's
just their cinnamon it's like their
Fireball version of Jack Daniels and I I
like it I would be untrue to myself you
like Jack dancer your little Saucy yeah
yeah you know what I like golf carts
Interstate 95 which stretches up and
down the east coast is Florida's busiest
Interstate according to the Federal
Highway Administration I will ask you
guys as we get out of here with this how
old how old is the woman in the center
lane on a golf cart on Saturday night
asleep a bag objective Tennessee whiskey
Tennessee fire whiskey do you now as our
guest you can go first Tigger third
where would you like to go in the order
I'll go first okay first I want to say I
like the idea of the journalist calling
the Federal Highway Administration
Federal Highway Administration I guess
how busy is that that it was the busiest
Highway yeah
if she's in the Middle Lane the semi had
to be in the at least third lane guide
her over to the first Lane which they're
in the second relay then guide her over
to the shoulder so if it was in the
middle of the process so wait if it was
the middle if she was in the far Middle
Lane yes or a middle lane or center lane
center
lane so I don't know if it's the center
of four four lane or three lanes or in
the center being the furthest the center
first went over in which case the semi
would have had gone on the median to
knock it says she's in the center lane I
imagine we're going three lanes yeah
three lanes middle Lanes okay that's
wild so what would you like to guess the
age on this woman
what are you feeling 47 47 years old 54.
54 from Randy scholar I feel like she
could be 76 or she could be 26 so I
don't know what to say so I'm gonna say
26. 26 years old how are you guys are
you just you're just picturing this
woman in your head and then yeah
Saturday night who is the type of woman
is she too young to not care or has she
been through enough heartbreak in my
life she's divorced and her got in a
fight with her boyfriend and said don't
tell me I'll go take myself boom I get
it takes his bottle of Tennessee stuff
and fire whiskey and it's like I'll show
him puts in a bag he's never gonna find
me he'll be looking on the golf course
26. she's 26 her she didn't want her she
didn't want to stay at this country club
with her parents oh yeah and she took it
out or her older boyfriend
was like he she saw her he he was being
mean to her abuse or whatever and she
went out in the garage grabbed his Jack
Daniels out of the out of the garage
refrigerator yeah freezer freezer it's
Tennessee fire whiskey bag that's out
there gets straight in that thing and
goes I'm gonna take and whatever happens
to me or to his golf cart we'll see what
happens or she has a lover uh the love
of her life is like leaving for the
Coast Guard and she's drunk thinking
about it and she's like you know what I
gotta get him I gotta tell him how yeah
let me get to him in the slowest way
the slowest dumbest most can't wait till
she gets the TSA yeah all right we'll
get out of here on this the guesses were
47 47 50 54 and 26.
John gemmerling wonderful to have you
here today
thank you for being saying that I got it
right she is
58 years old
by the way there you go guys that is a
show the world is dumb and we just try
and make fun of it in a fun way John
gammerling thanks for thank you so much
oh [__] we gotta get back to work y'all
[Music]
down